hey I'm bum casual got a chronograph
come back Michael Knight is like a
visible without you clarity husband like
my name is Gary B Sabah [ __ ]
I've been telling you how to talk about
Triple H ever the pedigree the meeting a
pleasure my faculties according to work
and I'm jernard the moving furniture
[Music]
hey guys so this is our new feature for
Monday as we continue to hack last week
we tried to do into the Week in Review
this week what we're doing and by the
way this is just because I'm trying to
really think about the work-life balance
thing obviously gives them some days a
lot of fun to be on Sunday so I will
film that in my workout on Saturday but
some of these I'm not going to probably
film instead with you Rach and I and
keen bad and are going to do is we're
going to focus on putting a full clip
from the week that we didn't show in its
entirety where I set it up as well here
and so this week's clip was an interview
I did which was much about more spaces
right like like these fall tables and
like smacks oh it's maxi rack next and
that's all that some other cool stuff
Facebook and Google does like what are
these couches and chairs and all these
things mean to the production of a
company I had a pretty interesting take
on here I think they feel at home
because I feel like I'm a parent and I
think all my actions between the room
they live in and the and the psychology
I deploy and the listening and the
talking you know I think people only
feel at home when the parents they could
feel at home I think it's a job of every
CEO yes businesses can start actually
giving a [ __ ] about people instead of
how much money they make because a funny
thing happens when you give a [ __ ] about
people you end up making more money I
mean I don't think it's unfortunate
those companies should then make what is
appropriate and all the people that work
there have you know this is you know
most people come from 8 most places in
the world have some level of freedom
they're more than welcome to start their
own company or work somewhere else you
know this whole narrative of like these
businesses or [ __ ] yes do I want
businesses to care about people more yes
it feels nice and it feels right it's a
legacy I want to leave and I think I'll
actually make some more money but do but
the employees aren't being you know
slaves it's not slavery right like be
yeah bit I mean everybody has to be
accountable this isn't just the man is
[ __ ] up where the business is [ __ ]
up the employees [ __ ] up with nourish
[ __ ] situation instead of going home at
5 o'clock and drinking beer and
complaining go on [ __ ] job listings
interviews Network
find a different [ __ ] job you know to
be very frank I you know the foosball
tables and the which we I think we have
a hockey thing because I like that the
the good cafeteria the free you know
granola I just think that's worship
those are tactics that [ __ ]
companies do to try to make people the
people are inspired and feeling good
because they feel safe and they feel
like they grow they feel like faith and
they feel like they can grow that's the
[ __ ] that matters not [ __ ] free
Cheerios on [ __ ] Tuesday for like for
like inspiration we I like putting up
signs and I do that [ __ ] but I don't
think people have been or happy and
killing it because I have a picture of
me saying your funeral matters that's up
there that stuff there because I like
that you know like like not because
that's there is a tactic it's all
religion they have to feel safe and they
have to feel like they can grow you know
and that's it
and like everything out like nobody's
going to put people by having 24-hour
massages in a [ __ ] room you know what
I mean
bandies everybody's got bandied nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your hardwood floor
or at a soda fountain machine the nice
but and we have them but I'm not the one
who's ever making that happen that's two
other people my company that decide
those things I've known interesting
bandied [ __ ] works because I give a [ __ ]
I mean look bro I'm going to give you
the shittiest interview ever I can feel
right because it's going to be the same
stuff like good good good because every
other year interviews are going to give
you [ __ ] answers here's the real
answer speak to people talk to them care
about them your first 10 employees are a
foundation of your company they're the
steel beams of the concrete at the
bottom of your building that nobody will
ever see they need to be into you and
you need to be into them I mean like and
the only way you get to that is speak
the truth communication the truth
communication the truth communication I
think the whole yeah no no no no no it's
okay
the ultimate for me the holy grail of
design and office space and things of
that nature is that it is not a tactic
to cover up the issues of the company
got it I don't I don't want I don't want
it to be a pretty dress you know like
and you're you're out of shape
underneath right like like like it needs
to it need to speak to the truth you
know which is you know if it's fancy
great you like fancy things good I mean
I'm not against anything everybody has
to do that but it can't be upfront you
can't be you can't be charming at the
bar and a [ __ ] boyfriend you know
what I mean good I'm glad it does
awesome and good luck my pleasure
take care hey guys one of things I
realized that I'm not doing enough of
and Thank You G Rock is subscribe to the
blog subscribe to the YouTube channel
please do that and also I would love to
get your favorite clip of this week
dailyvee please put it down on the low
for the hardcore fans please clip it put
the epic on number and the time for a
minute we've got some surprises for you
[Music]